good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is David as arad I'm an assistant
professor in a research fellow here at
the Van Andel Graduate School of
Government at Hillsdale colleges DC
campus and my pleasure to welcome you to
the event this evening with Chris
Caldwell regrettably our microphone is
not working it's working for those who
are listening to us online so we can't
project the voice any more than it does
naturally that being said when it comes
time to ask questions we will have a
microphone so that people who are tuning
in online can hear your question so
please wait for to be called upon and
have Claire come give you the microphone
it is our custom at Hillsdale to have a
student introduce the speaker and I'm
about to do that but before I do I just
want to make one quick plug for Chris's
book that I know will not be covered
this evening because this evening we're
going to discuss the substance of the
book I want to point out how marvelously
well-written it is I mean a lot a lot of
books get written today in America and
everywhere very very very few of them
are well written this one is admirably
well written I mean the words just
Sparkle on the page the prose moves
along nicely
it I know it's a cliche to say this but
once you pick it up you won't be able to
put it down not just because the
argument is so compelling and
provocative but Chris is really a
wonderful writer
that being said allow me to introduce
you to our host this evening Tests ants
who is a junior studying economics at
Hillsdale College at our main campus in
Michigan she's here this semester
interning at the capital research center
and taking classes here to tes
good evening ladies and gentlemen
tonight I had the distinct privilege of
introducing our speaker Christopher
Caldwell Christopher Caldwell is a
senior fellow and contributing editor of
The Claremont Review of Books he is a
contributing opinion writer for the New
York Times he is the author of
reflections on the revolution in Europe
immigration Islam and the West in a
claims study of the impact of the mass
emigration of Muslim immigrants to
Europe in the 20th century his newest
book the age of entitlement America
since the 60s which he will be
discussing tonight is a brilliant and
ambitious account of how the reforms of
the past 50 years left the country with
two incompatible political systems and
drove it towards conflict please join me
in welcoming Christopher Caldwell
that's very nice all right so without a
microphone I'm going to have to talk a
little louder and we'll sort of arrive
at an optimal volume
I think tell me if I'm too loud or or
too soft
I've been asked here this evening to
explain how American society has come to
be divided by party and by ideology in a
way that it maybe has not been since the
Civil War
I've just published a book as it happens
that I hope answers that question
Tess has described it thank you very
much test thank you David thank you Matt
Spaulding and everyone at Hillsdale for
having me here the book runs basically
from the assassination of John F Kennedy
to the election of Donald J Trump I
think you can get a good idea of the
drift of the narrative I say narrative
more than arguments you get a good idea
of the drift of the narrative from the
titles of it's eight chapters and they
are 1963 race sex war debt diversity
winners and losers
I can end part of the suspense right now
as we talk about parties which is the
Democrats are the winners the Democrats
are that are the party that of the
people who won the conflict of the 1960s
they gained money power and prestige
Republicans in general are the party of
the people who lost those conflicts now
in my book this argument has a number of
strands which I hope come together in a
in a useful or at least a coherent way
one strand involves the Vietnam War
there's a Vietnam played a very strange
part in in in in leaving behind a lot of
distortions in American life one thing I
focus on there
many aspects of the the war and the
protests against it that I focus on but
the way the army was mustered wound up
contributing to a class system and and
what I'm talking about here primarily is
the student deferment in the old days
university level specialist expertise
was rare and it made sense to keep those
who had it out of harm's way so for
instance at the start of World War one
only about 1 in 30 American men was in
university when you got into Vietnam
about one in two American men were in in
university and we still had this
deferment so if you were rich enough to
study art history you basically went to
Woodstock and you made love you know if
you were not rich enough you to when you
worked in a garage you went to Donna and
you made made war losing the war turned
this class problem that we had into
something very serious because it it
allowed the when we lost the war it
allowed the rich or the richer Americans
the better off Americans who
disproportionately did not participate
to mistake the class division for a
moral division the rich saw themselves
or the the better off saw themselves as
having avoided service in Vietnam not
because they were more privileged or
less brave or anything like that but
because they were more decent or more
far-seeing and I think that that was
corrosive one strand of the story
involved women today there are two
cultures of American womanhood there's a
culture of married women and a culture
of single women
if you pull them on political issues
they'll come up diametrically opposed on
on most of them it's tough to think of
two groups that differ more
during the Kennedy administration polls
showed that there was something like a
unified culture of of American womanhood
and and it United women from cradle to
grave if you asked questions of married
and Unwin unmarried women they'd answer
them exactly the same so 90% of married
women and 80% of 87% of unmarried women
believed there was such a thing as
women's intuition
16% of married women and 15% of
unmarried women thought it was okay
under certain highly defined
circumstances to have an affair outside
of marriage but a and and and 99% of
women of all ages believed that the
optimal age for marriage was under 27
and there were next to no responses for
never to that question so but there is
one strand of the argument in my book
that runs from beginning to end and it's
certainly the most important as far as
party is concerned and that concerns how
the civil rights laws of the 1960s and
particularly the Civil Rights Act of
1964 divided the country and they did so
I explained in the course of the book by
giving the country what was in effect a
second Constitution which caused
Americans to peel off into two different
and incompatible constitutional cultures
this became obvious only very slowly
only over time so slowly I think that
that people are still unable to see it
in many cases and since most of the
discussion in our official culture
concerns how the Civil Rights Act of
1964 brought the country together
suggesting that it might have pulled the
country apart has caused my book to
met with some controversy and outrage
now this outrage has been particularly
pronounced among one specific group of
Americans that is unfortunately very
large although I hope it will fall and I
mean those who have not read my book but
so so so for their benefit including
Eddie who might be inclined to review it
I should really make crystal clear okay
that this book is not a defense of
segregation or Jim Crow and that when I
criticize civil rights I am not
criticizing the impulse to equality in
general and I am not criticizing the
movement for black equality in
particular what I am talking about is
the system is the set of mechanisms that
in the name of ending segregation were
established and given to Washington as
tools these gave Washington the
authority to override what Americans had
traditionally thought of as their
ordinary democratic institutions they
were widely understood by the public as
temporary in local weather that
expectation was justified or not is
another question but they soon escaped
Democratic control altogether and they
have now become the most powerful part
of our governing system so let's talk
about how that worked I think that there
were two noteworthy things about the
civil rights legislation of 1964 and
1965 first as I said was it's
unprecedented concentration in power it
gave Washington tools that it had never
had in peacetime it created new crimes
with involving discrimination in many
walks of public and private life it
revoked
you if you wanted to put it strongly you
could say repeal
the prevailing understanding of freedom
of association that was implicit in in
the First Amendment it established new
agencies to hunt down those crimes so it
expanded the Civil Rights Commission it
established an Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission it set up various
offices of civil rights and the
different cabinet agencies that could
lay out guidelines that had the force of
law
it gave government new prerogatives like
laying out hiring practices for all
country companies with more than 15
employees filing certain lawsuits
conducting investigations ordering
redress I mean to put it as bluntly as I
do in the book The effect of these laws
was to take a lot of decisions that had
been made in the democracy and relocate
them either in the bureaucracy or in the
judiciary okay and so only with that
kind of arsenal Lyndon Johnson and the
drafters of civil rights legislation
thought would it be possible to root out
insidious racism okay the second thing
about these acts where they were
slightly a fudge as I say they sat
uneasily with parts of the Constitution
not just the First Amendment in the
Voting Rights Act of 1965 passed largely
to vindicate the 14th Amendment's
guarantee of equal citizenship did so by
creating different rights for citizens
regarding election laws depending on
whether you lived in Alabama or for
instance or whether you lived in
Michigan but really no one worried about
such things so much as long as it was
about segregation they were willing to
let it go
the goal of civil rights law was to
short-circuit the Sham democracies of
the American South and to bring them
into conformity with the Constitution
but it but nobody's democracy is perfect
and it turns out it turned out to be
harder to this
English between the South's democracy
and everyone else's so if the spirit of
the law was to humiliate southern bigots
and overturn southern segregation the
letter of the law put the entire country
and all of its institutions under
threats of lawsuits and prosecutions for
discrimination but as I say people were
not too worried about that it's clear in
retrospect the outside of the South most
Americans understood segregation as a
regional problem as far as we can
measure in polls you know 70 80 90
percent of people in the Northeast in
the Midwest if you asked them whether
black people were treated fairly in
their neighborhoods and their part of
the country would say yes they were
treated fine just the same as whites in
practice they did not expect these new
laws to be turned back on them the
problem is that when the work of civil
rights legislation was done when de jure
segregation was stopped these powers
were not stopped or scaled down or
reassessed on the contrary they
intensified the ability to set quotas
was not in the original legislation but
Offices of civil rights in the education
in hgw started doing that and there was
no one really strong enough to object
busing of school children was not in
this original legislation but once you
had these goals and guidelines for
integration in schools judges started
ordering it so you had many things
happening affirmative action is another
one that was a vague notion in the civil
rights bill but by the time of the Bakke
case the in in 1978 it had become an
outright system of racial preferences
and and
for those of you too young to remember
that case it involved a plaintiff Alan
actually he was not the plaintiff I
believe Alan Bakke who had been a marine
captain in in Vietnam
was rejected in his application for
medical school at the University of
California Davis despite having test
scores that were in the 96 94 97th and
72nd percentiles while minority
applicants in a special program were
admitted with scores that were on
average in the 34 30 30th 37 and 18th so
although the court decided that Bakke
deserved to be admitted it did not do
away with affirmative action in fact it
institutionalized it as long as it was
done in the name of diversity which was
a new concept at the time but another
thing another thing was happening and
that is that other groups many of them
not even imagined in the first civil
rights law got the hang of using civil
rights law
so immigrant advocates for instance no
one ever voted for bilingual education
but the Supreme Court okayed it in 1974
and real rural writers at the office of
civil rights in the in hgw established
it and it exists today women as well the
EEOC spent much of the 80s sort of
debating the family leave policy at at
Sears Roebuck
and so finally when you got into the 80s
civil rights came to dominate and even
overrule legislation that had seemingly
nothing to do with it and I think the
most traumatic example and lasting
example for the country was the
immigration reform and Control Act of
1986 I think this is an interesting case
it can be compared to certain Supreme
Court cases in the sort of like the
decades of yeah
think of like roe v-- wade in the
decades of of political strife that it
left in its wake
now burka as the bill was called was
supposed to be the grand compromise on
which our 21st century immigration
policy would be built on the one hand
about three million illegal immigrants
had come in from Mexico and other parts
of Latin America primarily and they were
to be given citizenship under under
Eartha but to keep that from
incentivizing further immigration there
were really draconian laws put in place
to ensure that immigration would never
get out of control that way again and so
what you had was very harsh penalties
called employer sanctions on any
employer who hired an illegal immigrant
so the law passed and and what happened
well the amnesty was for real it went in
into effect immediately but the
penalties turned out to be the the the
employer sanctions turned out to be not
workable because for an employer to ask
an employee who let's say looked Mexican
whether he was born in Mexico or what
his citizen was turned out to violate
his civil rights so in this case and in
others civil rights law made it
impossible for people to get the things
they had voted for in every law even in
areas like this which seemed to have
nothing to do with civil rights turned
into an expansion of this civil rights
law and if we had time we could look at
sort of further developments in in in in
later decades now basically more and
more areas of American life were
withdrawn from voters Democratic control
and subjected to the bureaucratic
judicial emergency powers of civil
rights law and here is where I say that
civil rights law had become a second
constitution with powers that could be
used to override the first and so now
we're at the heart of how these how the
parties have tended to come apart let's
talk about the Constitution that
resulted okay well I don't mean that it
has become the Constitution but it has
certain constitutional aspects and I'd
like to talk about two of these aspects
first this new civil rights Constitution
has a moral element almost a
metaphysical element that is usually
more typical of theocracies than of
secular Republic's it takes a little bit
of explaining as we've said civil rights
civil rights law gave emergency powers
to override the normal democratic
constitutional order but I think the key
question when it comes to such powers is
under what circumstances can government
activate these emergency powers and this
is kind of an edgy area of of European
political philosophy but I think it's a
very different question over there
because in Europe where you've had
problems with governments bypassing
their usual Constitution by means of
states emergencies it's usually on the
grounds of a military or security threat
or a threat to public order the American
regime increasingly did this for moral
emergencies so America can't wait there
are people who are suffering their
rights are being violated we got to do
this now every day that
gay person lives without being able to
be married there's suffering going on
and we can't mess around and wait for
the ordinary democratic process to take
its toll now a moral grounds for
invoking an emergency sounds much nicer
but actually in fact it can be kind of
pernicious because it requires that the
government in order to act create a
class of officially designated
malefactors in the Civil Rights original
civil rights legislation of 1964 the
justification of this strong medicine
was that you had a collection of
southern politicians who were so clever
and devious and and and a collection of
southern sheriff's who were so ruthless
and depraved that one could not and one
was not morally obliged to you know
fight them along according to marcus of
Queensbury rules and I must say that
that that that pattern holds even as the
focus of this sort of law has shifted
every intervention in the name of Rights
requires the identification of a
malefactor so very on in the gay
marriage debate those who believed in
traditional marriage were likened to
segregationists or to those who had
opposed interracial marriage earlier
this week Joe Biden the presidential
candidate said let's be clear
transgender equality is the civil rights
issue of our time there is no room for
compromise when it comes to basic human
rights now reading that through the lens
of the of the of the laws that we have
in the country since the 1960s
I take that to mean that
although Joe Biden and the rest of us
may still be getting to just learning
about transgender business and
everything I doubt Joe Biden is really
expert about it we're not going to be
able to we're not going to be able to
sort of like grope our way to an
understanding of it either through the
ballot box or through our legislatures
this is going to be decreed we're going
to be told by you know by a judge or
someone just what our policy towards
transgenderism is going to be so I'm
saying that as these laws were extended
into broader areas of American life this
imputation of moral non personhood was
aimed at a growing number of people who
had really done committed no sin more
Grievous than just sort of believing the
same things that they had believed five
years ago so so that's the first thing I
think the moral aspect of these laws the
second thing is more of a sociological
point and it has to do with what
activists progressive activists call
intersectionality as long as civil
rights was limited to southern blacks
and to ending segregation it was a
stable system it was not a sort of like
a moving part because it had the logic
of history behind it which both
justified it and focused it that is
limited in but if other groups could be
given the privilege of advancing their
rights by bureaucratic Fiat and judicial
decree then things got kind of
interesting in terms of electoral
politics because then there was the
possibility that you might gradually
build up vast new coalition's and maybe
even electoral majorities because almost
everyone who was not a white
heterosexual male could benefit from
civil rights law in some way
okay and this brings us to a sensitive
problem which you will understand a
little better if you followed the
constitutional politics of India India
had the first modern minority rights
based Constitution and a long enumerated
list of so-called scheduled tribes and
castes and that's what India's politics
has been about for much of the time
since the late late 40s eventually
negotiations between minorities and the
state took up so much of Indian
government's energy that there emerged
as a kind of a photographic negative a
group of Indians who were not covered in
these vast number of scheduled tribes
and classes and just sort of began to
grumble that you know there there
everyone except the people on that that
list and they are a big part of the
movement behind the present Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's coalition so if
you like Modi you say that he's the the
candidate of ordinary middle-class
Indians if you don't like him as most of
the international media and the elite
media and in India do not then you say
he's a Hindu nationalist okay and we
have a version of the same thing
happening I would say in this country
and in retrospect it was evident in the
mid 80s when this intersectional
coalition came up with the term people
of color to describe itself a lot of
what I do in the book is described
shifts in language that are kind of
telling but this this one is really
particularly striking because logically
if there is such a thing as a coalition
of people of color demanding that they
be given more out of society they're
demanding that it be gotten from people
not of color and so as in the same way
that
that the the that the the Indian
Constitution called forth this idea of
like a generic Hindu the new civil
rights Constitution created a group of
non people of color it made white people
a political reality in the United States
in a way that they had never been so
while this constitution didn't disfavor
whites it favored every other group that
it touched and whose interests it it
protected which amounts to the same
thing
and now you can see a little bit where
we're going with this as we discuss
parties so overwhelming I think is the
hegemony of this 1964 Constitution over
the 1788 Constitution that our politics
has pretty naturally sorted itself into
a party of those who have been helped by
the new constitutional developments and
a party of those who have been harmed by
it so let's say let's say you're a gay
man in a gay marriage with two adopted
children okay
the civil rights version of your country
has to appear constitutional it's not
optional it's your your whole way of
life depends on it
your entire life depends on it how could
you even consider backing a party or a
politician who even questioned that or
wavered it wavered on it so quite likely
in fact if you're in that position your
whole moral idea of yourself - depends
on your relationship to this new
constitution you may have marched in gay
pride parades carrying signs that say
things like stop the hey you know and
you have an idea that people who opposed
your campaign who oppose the campaign
that brought you your life that brought
you the
to marry that brought you your children
can only have done so for absolutely
terrible reasons you are on the side of
the glorious marchers of Birmingham and
they are on the side of Bull Connor it
is quite natural that you would
understand the opponents of your way of
life as a party of bigots okay meanwhile
across town okay if you are a
conservative person who goes to church
and your seven-year-old son is being
taught about gender fluidity in first
grade and there's really no Avenue for
you to complain and in fact you don't
know quite what the laws are because
you're not like a law professor but you
have a vague sense that if you if you
complain to the if you complain to the
principal you might like lose your job
or something or get ostracized in your
community meanwhile you're getting
called an enemy of civil rights but you
kind of sense that that what's going
wrong in your kids schools and the
reason you can't bring them up the way
you want to has got something to do with
with gay marriage and then you look up
and you say sorry I voted for this when
and into him so to him the other party
is a party of totalitarians and that is
our system okay you have the party with
the bigots and the party of the
totalitarians okay and in it it doesn't
when you look at it that way and I think
that a lot of members of these parties
do look at it that way it is really
tough to see where our common ground is
going to be found in the coming years I
would I would say that if either of
these constitutions who was totally
devoid of merit we wouldn't have a
problem I mean we could just be
confident that you know the wiser of the
two would would win out by attrition in
the end the problem is that each of the
Constitution's
and you must remember that the 1964
Constitution is now well over half a
century old each of our two
constitutions has for its adherence a
great deal that is worth fighting over
and defending to the bitter end and
unfortunately each Constitution seems to
be defending itself against the others
and so you know when gay marriage was
being advanced twenty years ago I mean
one of the common morale-boosting
sayings of the activists was hey the sky
didn't fall you know so people would say
hey look we've had gay marriage and in
Massachusetts for three months now and I
Got News for You right-wingers the sky
didn't fall you know I think that and
they were right in what they said but I
think that they forgot how delicate a
system Democratic constitutional
republic is and how difficult it is to
get the formula right and how hard it is
to see when a government begins slowly
very slowly to veer off course in a way
that can take decades to become evident
until one day we discover that although
we say that the sky is not falling we're
saying it with a lot less conviction
than we used to thank you very much
[Applause]
so if you want to raise your hands for
questions and clear
exactly with the sky falling look like I
mean I point but ordinary or something
well I you know yeah whoo I think that
that in the in the actual context of the
battles over gay marriage in
Massachusetts I think that they were
referring to
you know the warnings that there would
be a breakdown in you know social the
sort of like social mores and norms and
that kind of thing but and that indeed
did not happen so my point in raising it
was only to say that IIIi believe that
people have different time horizons I
just think that they're the two sides in
that case as in our case we're kind of
talking past each other
so it seems to me that the Civil Rights
Act the Voting Rights Act were passed
under the so the legislative enactment
from the 13th and 14th amendment and I
think on some level everybody here would
agree that you know that was necessary
the Civil Rights Act as you pointed out
you know when focused on segregation in
the south was necessary and justified
the problem we have comes when it has
sort of creeped out into literally
everything else do you see that given
the fact that I mean I think certainly
many definition I would note you know it
was constitutional to the old
Constitution as you put it I mean is it
a legal matter the is it the is it the
administrative structure is it the legal
matter is it just a political drift that
has made this inevitable I mean well it
was this inevitable I guess you know
given the structure of everything that
came before it as I'm trying to say
anything this is something that has been
nagging at me through the whole project
of of writing this book and I think I I
think I know what what people missed a
little bit at the beginning and I think
that
I'm not sure I do not you know in fact I
do not believe that people passed these
law these laws were powerful tools I
don't think people thought of them
primarily as tools I think they were
thinking primarily of segregation and
stopping it but here these tools were
the question is why did it spread so
quickly to other to other stuff why did
it become the go to the go to governing
tool and I think the reason is I think
the Achilles heel in in the legislation
may have been that by giving so much
power to judges and and regulators it
failed to see how the two of them could
have this kind of like ricocheting sort
of like pong type relationship between
each other over the heads of the
legislators and the voters and the work
there's a political scientist at Boston
College named Shep Melnick who's written
absolutely extraordinary things about
how a regulatory finding you know in in
an Office of Civil Rights gets turned
into a constitutional precedent in a in
a Supreme Court case and then it becomes
grounds for the this same office to go
into a whole new area so that was very
the failure to see that was key but I
also think that that they failed to see
that it was the exact same people who
were exercising power under civil rights
type rule who would be asked whether it
was constitutionally or governmentally
justified to extend that rule so if you
go to the Supreme Court
and say is it alright that judges decide
what marriages and the judges say sure
do you know what I mean
that so that I think was the week the
week achilles heel that's it thank you
for the talk talk it was brilliant and
bold there is there's a kind of a sense
of oppressor and oppressed Marxist
template that seems to be applied before
these laws kick in and I think you know
the the Frankfurt School pushed that
into the states in the 40s and 50s and
it got into the civil rights movement
which was probably apt there but it's
become now a common trope you know or
men of oppressed women and this sort of
thing do you feel that's been part of
this this problem and if so yes in in in
two ways I you know I will say I found
very useful in studying this problems
the writings of the group of mostly
black academic legal theorists who
mostly left-wing who wrote in the 1990s
called the critical race theory there's
one of them there's one of them in who
is a professor who hasn't written very
much but he's written a couple of
brilliant essays on the subject named
Alan David Freeman and and and he writes
about the difference between the the the
victim perspective and the perpetrator
perspective and I actually find it a
very fruitful way to look at things and
it explains how you can have a
discussion between two well-meaning
people totally at cross-purposes okay so
in the case of of segregation you have
the you have the white perpetrators and
the black victims now they're going to
have a very different attitude of when
this is working
with the best faith in the world if you
are a black person growing up under
segregation this is a system that takes
all sorts of stuff away from you you
know the you know money opportunities
job comfort family life and things like
that and you're not going to feel that
the justice injustice has been remedied
until those deficits have been supplied
okay but if you're from the perpetrator
people if you're just like you know
let's say a journalist or a lawyer in
some southern town you you don't like
segregation and you think it's really
bad okay but you think that you know you
think that the the sheriff is a jerk you
think the mayor is corrupt you hate the
way they you know they talk about race
but you think that as soon as people
start being good it's gonna be fine
so you're fine you're not you don't owe
anyone anything you are behaving like a
like a like a like a moral person and so
there's no problem as far as you
concerned that I found so I just I say
that just to sort of like can say it
convey that I think this question a
victim and perpetrator is a genuine one
in in in in many cases the thing that I
was trying to get to earlier is that you
need to activate to activate a moral
crusade around rights you need to
designate someone as a malefactor and I
think that you know that's the way the
the law has developed
Thanks Thank You mr. Cole well that was
impressive I'm having a little
difficulty with the premise that it
seems to me you're saying that the
gentleman that you refer to as saying
when did I vote for this the premise
being there that certain issues rights
issues that we're talking about here
whether it be african-american rights or
gay rights or LBG whatever rights are
subject to the democratic process it
seems to me this constitutional
democracy makes an exception for rights
from the democratic process that rights
are settled in the judiciary and not the
legislators and so the the activism of
the 70s in which the left turned to the
judicial to the judiciary to get their
way was appropriate in my am I thinking
except for the fact that what is a right
and it seems to me that that's where the
battle is defining what our inalienable
rights and therefore what rights should
be settled by the judiciary and what
should be settled by the legislature
could you comment on it well I think
that there are some there are some
spectacular you know instances of the
court stepping into you know declare
rights in American history but I think
that before I mean you have had
interventionist courts before like in in
Dred Scott for instance in the 19th
century but I think that in general
before Brown versus Board of Education
in 1954 which seemed to be an isolated
case the rights were what was in the
Constitution you want new rights amend
the Constitution you know I think that
was the idea of what a right was you
didn't you couldn't just go creating
rights on the say-so of a legal theory
or or or a judicial preference so I
think that the the the this question of
what is a right I think was more easily
resolved and more stable than it has
become
Chris the great bottom enjoy your book
point well-taken learn about the courts
force of legislators provide a question
here you've posed the possibility of two
constitutions six for constitution in
the original Constitution implied that
perhaps we might be issues between them
I just think we've never actually had a
little choice director it puts the
American people but I wondered whether
you think that we're at the point where
we can't choose anymore it's actually
too late what number two how do we read
the 2016 election is it some evidence
that there might be lots of American
people out there who would like to make
that choice because they would like to
choose a once-great country ours we read
it as the death throes of a dying
for our economy give us the choice was
Detroit what is their choice and what do
you think you know I if you don't if you
don't mind I'd like to say something
about em choosing in general because I
have you know I open the book by saying
that people increasingly felt like they
have to choose and I should make clear
and that the what really drove me to
talk about choosing between these two
constitutions is is something that's in
the center of the book that we didn't
really touch on tonight
which is that running large deficit what
having two constitutions satisfying the
needs of two groups who think very
differently about what the country
exists for is very expensive and I
believe it's the source of our chronic
deficits for the last 40 years when I
talked about choosing in the book what I
most often mean is that as it becomes
more difficult or more problematic to
access credit as it did after 2008 it's
tough to buy off the sides who are
disappointed by buy one settlement for
the other is it too late to to choose
well I'll tell you I I mentioned you
know a few minutes ago that you know
this 64 Constitution has been been there
for almost 60 years
there are people who really depend on it
it's very interesting to see that you
know it clearly not to go too far afield
okay it clearly makes incursions on the
bill of rights including the First
Amendment and not just the ones on
Association that I'm talking earlier I
mean the idea that the Supreme Court
could rule so equivocal II on a on a you
know sort of like a decorator a gay
marriage cake case is a sign I think
that that the
first amendment is giving a bit of way
to this new constitution so when I say
that the two are in conflict I'm not I'm
not calling for people to like come back
to their senses and restore you know I
don't I do not I don't know what's gonna
happen but I don't see that as a as an
immediate possibility so what this trump
mean which is your third your third
question that's a place where I
conveniently end the book but I but I do
think it has to do now I've talked about
the moral aspect of these of this
legislation which i think is really
important the moral and metaphysical
aspect you know the United States was
always a pretty live-and-let-live kind
of place it wasn't it didn't have a
theme and you hear you you hear people
you know talking about these ideals of
different rights and you know the right
to love and then and all these kind of
these kind of things there is a whole
there's a whole set of narratives I
think that come along with this this new
constitution and they may be they may be
what endears a lot of the pub of the
public to them but there's a large
number of Americans who are not
protagonists in this narrative and I
think that like a lot of like a lot of
cruelty there's just a lot of people
that no one's really gone out and tried
to you know you know really do a bad
turn to anyone who's you know who lives
in a in a formerly great manufacturing
town but I think they've kind of
forgotten about them you know and that I
think is that is what Trump has to do
with I think it's the the people who've
been forgotten in the more recent
narrative
and were they
aside from trouble you know what is it a
sign of yeah it's a sign of a it's a
sign of an in is a sign perhaps of a an
increasing consciousness among these
people because these trends are not new
it's a sign that they're beginning to to
find themselves and sort of like
coalesce into a kind of movement perhaps
the best one is that the biggest problem
is that the idea of this whole movement
was to create equality of opportunity
and we have been moves not to create I
wanted equality a certain portfolio of
all terms which have to dominate the
other consideration and the rice today
you know people eat health care rights
the policy people are talking about
abuse so the whole Eli's discussion has
to move from right opportunity and the
right to be left a long enough to be
harmed in the rights of you getting
resources from other people to satisfy
certain needs and objectives and I think
that's and therefore the deficits as
well
that's a subject that that that
interests me it's not what I deal with
in in my book so I'll let your comment
stand yeah thank you for a very
thought-provoking lecture I've two
points of confusion that you don't
necessarily need to explain now number
one I think John Winthrop would contest
your assertion that America is a live
and let live nation we have a long
history of moral leaders and that is a
very strong strain in our political and
intellectual discourse so that's
something that that's an impulse that
must always be grappled with
particularly coming from New England the
second is a little confused about how
the Civil Rights Act has augmented our
national debt when the biggest driver of
our national debt is Social Security
which was instituted prior to the Civil
Rights Act but my real question is it
seems you actually want to build on the
gentleman's comments about rights and
the stability of Rights and it's hard
for me to imagine that even the 13th
14th and 15th amendments are can be
considered truly stable when they were
bought at the cost of 600,000 American
lives that is that that was a debate
that had to be sorted in blood
so can it possibly is a third way
between these two constitutions the the
conception that although not ideal
sometimes the courts and sometimes the
administrative state might be a better
battleground than then an outright Civil
War so I want to I want to see if
there's any space in your argument for
that consideration that previous rights
have been fought over coarser ground
yeah I'm not that's an interesting
theory that that the the fact that blood
was shed to obtain the 13th 14th and
15th amendment makes them less stable I
think some people would say it makes
them more stable but I I don't know now
as for you know choosing the
administrative state as a battleground I
you know this is a you know as I
explained sometimes this is really a
narrative it's a it's a history it's not
a a manifesto or or a policy book but
the but the things I've you know I've
written about and thought about lead me
to believe that the the problem with
attempting to if I understand you
correctly replicate some of our old
democratic debates within the
administrative state is that the
administrative state is kind of a
one-party state so I don't think it's a
for people it's a I don't think it's too
promising actually as a you know as an
avenue for productive policymaking now
the question of whether it beats you
know sort of like civil war and things
which is what you seem to be implying is
a is it is another question yeah Chris
we'll stay here to sign books so you can
be part of the growing number of people
who've bought the book whether or not
you read it may be up to you then
[Applause]